.
HERSCHEL WALKER, GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
THANK YOU.
LINDSEY GRAHAM, THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOU BOTH WITHING WITH
US.
IN THE GREAT STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA, FAR LEFT, THE GUY
THAT THINKS HALLOWEEN IS EVERY
DAY OF THE YEAR AND TRIES TO
MASQUERADE AS A WORKING GUY,
JOHN FETTERMAN, THE TRUST FUND
BRAT IN A HOODIE IS LITERALLY
STRUGGLING AS MUCH AS AND HIS
CAMPAIGN IS WARNING THAT VOTES
WILL NOT BE FULLY COUNTED UNTIL
DAYS AFTER THE ELECTION.
FETTERMAN HAD ANOTHER MAJOR
MISHAP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TODAY, DR. OZ IS GOING TO BE
STANDING WITH DONALD TRUMP ON
THE STAGE.
I'M GOING TO BE STANDING WITH
THE PRESIDENT THAT IS 100%
SEDITION-FREE.
I WANT TO SERVE PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Sean: YOU SEE EVERY AMERICAN
FLAG GO WHOPPING DOWN THERE?
HE'S SURGING AT THE RIGHT TIME.
LOOK AT THIS NEW POLL SHOWING
HIM AHEAD OF FETTERMAN.
DR. OZ JOINS US NOW TO EXPLAIN.
STILL CLOSE.
SAY HELLO TO OUR FRIENDS IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
I LOVE CHEESE STEAKS.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE EATING CHEF
BOYARDEE TONIGHT.
>> I'M PROUD OF YOU.
I'M IN MONTGOMERY COUNTY.
I'VE BEEN TRAVELING THE
COMMONWEALTH.
I'M HOME.
BEHIND ME THERE'S A CROWD OF
EVERYBODY 1,000 PEOPLE I JUST
SPOKE TO.
TO YOUR POINT, THE MAIN ARGUMENT
WAS MAKING, WASHINGTON KEEPS
GETTING IT WRONG BECAUSE OF ITS
RADICAL IDEAS.
JOHN FETTERMAN WILL BE MORE
RADICAL FOR POLICIES THAT WILL
BE DESTRUCTIVE.
TO FOLLOW UP WHAT LINDSEY GRAHAM
HAS SAID, THE MOST DANGEROUS
THING HE PROMISED TO DO, BLOW UP
THE FILIBUSTER AND PACK THE
COURT AND GET ALL OF THESE LAWS
PASSED THAT ARE NOT ALIGNED WITH
THE VALUES OF PEOPLE HERE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THAT'S WHY I'M GOING TO WIN
TOMORROW.
>> Sean: YOU LOOK AT THE GUY
YOU'RE RUNNING AGAINST, LOOK AT
HIS RECORD.
HE WANT TO LEGALIZE DRUGS IN THE
STATE -- IN THE COMMONWEALTH OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
HE'S THE BIGGEST PRO CRIMINAL.
HE'S ADVOCATED FOR MORE
CONVICTED MURDERS TO GET OUT OF
JAIL THAN ANY ONE PERSON.
LEGALIZE DRUGS AND TAX PLAYERS
TO PAY FOR HEROIN INJECTION
SITES AND NO RESTRICTIONS ON
ABORTION AND MORATORIUM ON
FRACKING AND NO DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
THAT COST THE COMMON WEALTH $83
BILLION.
HE WANTS TO SUE GROCERY STORES
AND OIL COMPANIES.
HE WANT SANCTUARY CITIES AND
SANCTUARY STATES.
WHY HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS WHOLE
CAMPAIGN.
BUT FOR THE ONE-HOUR DEBATE, THE
MEDIA SO CORRUPT HAS NEVER ASKED
FOR ANY EXPLANATION ON ANY OF
THESE ISSUES.
HE'S LIKE JOE BIDEN.
HIDING IN THE BASEMENT.
THE LESS YOU TALK, THE BETTER.
SEND OUT SURROGATES TO TALK FOR
YOU AND ACT AS THOUGH EVERYTHING
IS OKAY AND THE MEDIA LETS HIM
GET AWAY WITH THAT.
HAVING A DEBATE FIVE WEEKS AFTER
VOTING STARTS?
THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR.
THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE IN THE
FUTURE.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> YOU CAN'T FOOL THE VOTERS OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
THEY'RE ON TO HIM NOW.
THAT ONE DEBATE WAS ENOUGH.
THEY GOT TO SEE WHY HE'S UNABLE
TO SEE WHY HE HAS THE FAR LEFT
RADICAL POSITIONS THAT ARE OUT
OF TUNE WITH WHAT MOST
PENNSYLVANIANS BELIEVE.
THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE BASED ON
WHAT THEY THINK IS BEST FOR THE
COUNTRY AND THE COMMONWEALTH.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING DOCTORS
DO IS LISTEN.
WE LISTENED TO VOTERS.
THEY TELL ME THE SAME STORY.
THE ECONOMY IS DESTROYING THEIR
LIVES, THEY'RE UNABLE TO MAKE A
SAFE COMMUNITY SO THEY CAN SEND
THEIR KIDS INTO AND DON'T TRUST
THEIR MAILBOXES BECAUSE THERE'S
FENTANYL SHOWING UP ALL THE
TIME.
THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE BECAUSE
THEY'RE ANGRY, FRUSTRATED AND
DON'T FEEL LIKE ANYBODY IS
LISTENING.
THAT SAID THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
A SOCIAL EXPERIMENT BEING RUN BY
PEOPLE LIKE JOHN FETTERMAN.
MY BIG SPEECH TONIGHT WAS ABOUT
BELIEVING IN THEM.
LISTEN, I BELIEVE THAT WE'LL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
I BELIEVE WE'RE THE LAND OF
PLENTY.
I BELIEVE WE CAN BALANCE A
BUDGET.
I BELIEVE WE CAN HAVE SAFE
CITIES AND STREETS AND I BELIEVE
WE CAN HAVE A SECURITY BORDER TO
HAVE LEGAL IMMIGRATION WORK
AGAIN.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, I BELIEVE IN
YOU.
THE VOTERS OF PENNSYLVANIA.
THEY BELIEVE IN ME.
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE GOING TO
CARRY THE DAY TOMORROW.
I THINK WHEN ALL THE DUST HAS
SETTLED, WHAT YOU SAID IS
CORRECT, BUT THE VOTERS WILL NOT
BE FOOLED BY A NARRATIVE THAT
DID NOT TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT
WHAT JOHN FETTERMAN STOOD FOR.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THEY'RE
VERY RESPECTFUL BEHIND YOU.
YOU CAN TELL THEM I SAID HELLO
AND THEY CAN WAVE TO THE CROWD.
>> HE SAID HI, YOU CAN CHEER.
>> Sean: I'M ON TV.
HELLO.
>> I COULDN'T GET THEM QUIET.
THEY WOULDN'T STOP.
>> Sean: THEY WERE BEING
RESPECTFUL.
BY THE WAY, DR. OZ, IS IT
HEALTHY TO EAT CHEF BOYARDEE?
THAT'S THE DEMOCRATIC PLAN IF
YOU CAN'T AFFORD GROCERIES.
IT'S $1.99 A CAN.
IS THAT A GOOD IDEA?
>> SEAN, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NO
AGENDA FOR PROSPERITY.
IT'S NOT JUST THE FOOD.
IT'S ENERGY PRICES, WHERE YOUR
KIDS ARE GOING TO SCHOOL.
THEY'RE NOT TAKING US ANYWHERE.
REPUBLICANS HAVE BETTER IDEAS.
LET'S WIN THIS ELECTION TOMORROW
AND LET THE BETTER IDEAS SHINE
FORWARD.
GO TO DR. OZ.COM.
WE HAVE ALL OF OUR IDEAS THERE.
IF YOU WANT TO SUPPORT US, GET
INVOLVED.
CALL FRIENDS OF YOURS IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND GET THEM TO
VOTE.
WE DON'T WANT TO GRAB DEFEAT
FROM THE JAWS